what random action movies are you into  recently or anything you're obsessed  with recently  i mean i'm not my brave heart right now  seriously um random action movies that  i've seen  i don't know can we talk about a tv show  [Applause]  if actually they asked you to direct any  of yellowstone would you do it  you know like i said i would not want to  do star wars five because i i as like  really scott said the greatest and  toughest thing for director to do is  create to create the world and i like  creating the world but that might be fun  i mean i just the horses and the stets  and hats and just a beautiful landscape  [ __ ] it's a fun show i would love to see  you doing  you